welcome to another dr sadler's honest
reviews this is a series in which i
review mostly recent works in philosophy
very broadly speaking practical
philosophy self-help leadership all
sorts of other things as well and the
book that i have today is by a friend
and colleague massimo pigliucci it is a
field guide to a happy life 53 brief
lessons for living and it's a little you
know almost pocket book
it's 150 pages but they are some pretty
you know short pages so this is
something that you could easily
read your way through
in less than an afternoon
it's come out fairly recently from basic
books so 2020 first edition perhaps
we'll see some more editions of this
coming out
in the future and as usual i'm going to
tell you a little bit about the style
and structure
and summary some of the key points of
the works what i think is good about the
book what i think is problematic about
the book and then i'll wrap up from
there
so
i think this is kind of an interesting
book to look at in terms of its
structure first because it really does
have
an unusual
way in which it is
set up there's several different parts
the bulk of which is the actual
field guide part two which is divided
into six sections and then that is book
ended by part one titled betting on the
philosopher's slave the philosopher's
slave obviously is epictetus and there's
a couple different kinds of things
in there as well and then we have part
three
stoicism 2.0 and then there's
two appendices to it and some
acknowledgements and and some notes in
the end of it
so there's there's a lot of different
things packed into this but you could
say that the
the central structure of it
is massimo pigliucci
taking epictetuses and caridian which is
one of the most famous works of stoic
philosophy it's one of the things that
in intro to philosophy classes or ethics
we often throw at students as a
representative of stoicism it has had a
long and storied history uh throughout
the ages as well and it's you know it's
fairly short and kind of
pithy and packed and punchy you could
say and what massimo is doing
in most of this book well at least in a
good part of this book is taking
epictetuses and coridian and updating it
for a late modern age in which
we might not buy into all of the things
that epictetus
is advocating or that aryan represents
epictetus is advocating since aryan
wrote down these
discourses and also
the um
and caridian is sort of a best hits list
and massimo is is doing this quite
deliberately and thoughtfully and
consciously and explaining what he's
doing along the way
if we if we begin at the beginning right
with this
after we get past the praise for it
betting on the philosopher slave part
one we have a little bit of a you know
story of um
epictetus
and and why
uh massimo himself got interested in him
a lot of it is is actually talking more
about epictetus um and his and then
massimo's uh discovery and how he
incorporated it into his own practice
and life and you know if you don't know
who massimo is a little bit of
background he is one of the big you know
representatives of modern stoicism he
belongs to the same organization modern
stoicism limited and he does a lot of
blogging and podcasting and
events and things like that connect and
writing books connected with with
stoicism he also had a long career prior
to that as well both in biology and in
philosophy
so
he talks a bit about epictetus and then
we have the how to use this book he says
that this is a book to carry around with
you the first section is meant as a
general introduction to stoicism and
epictetus use it as a quick for
refresher
the field guide is the second section
and then
the third and last section of the guide
is a hand handy summary of how modern
stoicism at least in my version diverges
from the original
keeping in mind that stoicism has
constantly been altered and updated then
he's got a you know sort of thing on
it's called stoicism 101 and it you know
it's going over some really really basic
stuff
it's very short and then finally he gets
to epictedian philosophy 101 so this is
a subdivision you could say of stoic
philosophy and in many respects a
reinterpretation of it and he gives you
some uh guidance about what's what's
going on there and we'll come back to
that in a bit then we have the the field
guide and the field guide is divided
into
really five main sections that have to
do with the n caridian
they're each of them has titles and
you know they're supposed to be um
bringing
certain sections of the n caribbean
which is by the way not organized in a
thematic fashion although people do like
massimo is here read in
themes to it as as being parts of
section so
here's here's the the sections setting
things straight where you learn the most
important and practical lesson of them
all that's the first one second one
training your desires and aversions
where you begin to reorient your likely
misguided desires and aversions
third training to act in the world where
you prepare yourself to behave justly
towards other people
fourth training yourself to think better
where you prepare yourself to improve
your judgments about things in people
fifth training to live well where you
prepare yourself to practice the art of
living and then there's finally a sixth
section which is just four very short
passages um from epictetus four pieces
of advice from epictetus where we listen
to the master and like i said that's the
bulk of this work and you know as you
can see
very short that you can you know check
out
read mull over meditate on
i should actually mention at this point
before we finish the the
structure part that the style
is you know typical massimo very clear
except for a few points that i'm going
to mention when the problematic thing
modern language easy to read easy to
grasp i think you know that's actually a
high point of massimo's books
so you know here's an example from
section 37 we all play several roles in
life but suppose you've decided to play
a role that's not appropriate to you or
beyond your abilities if you were an
actor you would have ruined the play for
the spectators the other actors and
yourself so consider carefully what
projects you engage in and whether
you're suitable for them and by the same
token be sure not to neglect some other
projects for which you are in fact well
suited now if you've read epictetus's
zen caridian
that will sound familiar to you but if
things are being moved around and you
know spoken of in a different way and
that's that's really the style of what's
going on in this section
and then finally we get to the
last part where
stoicism 2.0 one section is called
updating stoicism
and it goes through a number of
different themes where massimo says that
listen you know stoicism needs to be
rethought in this way or this way and
then we have uh the second section this
is not the first time and it won't be
the last which is essentially a
discussion about
how the
the end caribbean
and stoic philosophy has been updated
and whether whether that's okay to do or
not and then we have these appendices
now
appendix one is very useful a conceptual
map of the differences between the end
caridian
and the field guide so
you can see here it's a sort of you know
side by side comparison
of what's going on in the original and
caridian and what's going on in mossy
malls updated field guide very helpful i
think
then there's also a
annotated bibliography
not bad you know rather short
and you know it it sort of represents a
good picture of the people massimo
himself is is particularly
engaged with so that gives you a good
idea about what's going on in terms of
the structure of the work and also a
little bit about the style
when we're thinking about the main ideas
of this work uh because of the very
nature of
this as a updated and caribbean with
some as i mentioned
bookended materials before and after
a lot of the main ideas are those of
epictetus's interpretation of stoicism
so for example the dichotomy of control
is an important one the distinction
between what's in our power what's not
in our power or you know not in our
control or not our business not up to us
that's you know a central stoic idea
there's other ideas about role ethics
and following our roles and discerning
what they are there's a lot of practices
built in about how to deal with what the
stoics called appearances or impressions
fontasii in the greek
you know ways in which we can rethink
and reapply ourselves when we get to
determinate situations how to prioritize
properly
how not to allow things to get to us or
get us down when they don't have to
how to tell if we're making progress all
sorts of things like that are in the end
caribbean and so
necessarily they're going to be here
in massimo's reinterpretation
i will mention another thing you know
this is something that shows up very
early on and this shows up pretty
consistently in massimo's work and he's
not he's not unique in this
pier doe does this as well
there's a big emphasis on what are
called the three disciplines
this is coming from a passage in
epictetus where he goes over what these
disciplines are we don't actually know
whether this was you know um epictetus
putting his own spin on things or an
orthodox stoic position seneca actually
talks about three different disciplines
matias we'll talk about three other
disciplines later on in in one of the
passages in in this so it's a little bit
uh tricky but massimo is using that as a
sort of organizing structure so we have
the discipline of desire and aversion
the discipline of action also sometimes
called the discipline of choice right
and then the discipline of ascent and so
those provide a kind of framework
structure
the whole idea of updating stoicism that
is a
big thing not just you know
found in the last
section but
running throughout the entire work
because that is massimo's project
stoicism 2.0 and he tells you what he
thinks that means and i think it would
be good for us to go and look at those
themes so we're kind of starting
at the end
he tells us that
we should go back to the classic
distinctions the stoics themselves made
between logic physics and ethics he
talks about you know what they meant by
that a bit he proposes that the stoic
philosophical recipe boils down to logic
plus physics equals ethics and then we
get to these these themes so theme one
externals don't need to be
despised
and this is an important departure from
some of the stuff that epictetus is
saying and you'll actually find in
the the field book places where
massimo is saying externals are
externals right they they don't have
value in and of themselves but we don't
have to despise them
that's a little bit over the top theme
two there's no need to cultivate
indifference to human loss this is a big
sticking point for many people reading
epictetus and thinking about stoicism
how should we understand loss grief
matters like that theme number three
live according to nature which basically
here massimo brings up the passage from
diogenes laertes where you know we get
two different kinds there's the the
nature of the universe that we have to
adapt ourselves to so you know not
kicking against fate or not believing
physical things to work in ways they
don't work and then instinctively human
nature which is rational and social
and that's again
very common in massimo's work to
interpret it that way
theme four is very interesting
questionable science or metaphysics
massimo is is making the case that
listen we no more than we need to buy
into like aristotelian metaphysics do we
or physics rather do we have to buy into
stoic physics about the way the world
works we can update it with you know
better understandings coming from
physics or biology
theme five god or adams and he says this
is perhaps the most radical change i'm
proposing
uh you know we we can say that we don't
really
need to have a providential ordering
it's it's kind he says i find the stoic
notion of providence beautiful and
comforting
but as a scientist living in the 21st
century i can't accept it we have no
reason to believe that the sentience is
a property of the cosmos uh or that
there is any such thing as the panoma or
similar all permeating substance or that
the universe is any way like a living
organism so we can you know kind of put
that off and this is quite a long
section uh here
theme six this i think this is very
important too
local customs are neither universal nor
immutable
and you know he uses the example of
epictetus
not really having much to say about
slavery other than that you know real
slavery is being a slave to your desires
or those who control the things that
your desires are aimed after
and just leaving those sort of cultural
assumptions about slavery
there we could think also about
epictetus and his insistence that a man
wants to have a beard or else he's being
effeminate we can say well that's that's
a matter of that culture we don't have
to buy
into that and and we can talk about
cultural progress and then theme seven
is social justice uh and this is this is
quite important you know the stoics
really really did stress justice and no
interpretation of stoicism
is a real interpretation if it puts
justice aside and
you know
stoic justice would include much of what
we these days call
social justice
so you know for example he says
there's no reason whatsoever within
stoicism to discriminate on the basis of
sex gender ethnicity or any other
arbitrary or biological categorization
of human beings
on the contrary the fundamental notion
of a stoic notion of cosmopolitanism
entails any such discrimination ought to
be rejected as incompatible with stoic
philosophy that's dead-on he's actually
quite correct both about ancient
stoicism and about how we ought to
understand in in the present
so those are some you know really
important main ideas i would say
uh that gives you a good sense about
what's going on in this book
i will say this too because of the
organization of the book
you're getting a lot of the
key ideas in exactly this form in
little
nuggets that you can
read think about
assimilate
and then you know try to apply see if
you succeed
and then come back to so this would
become like a genuine field book that
you would use over and over again i
think that gives you a good
idea about what the key ideas plural are
in this little field book
all right let's talk about some of the
good points of this work i i want to say
right off the bat that
the idea of taking epictetuses
and caridian and
not just rewording it for a modern
audience but sort of critically
assessing
what needs to be updated and what can
stay the way it is it's actually a
pretty brilliant idea i kind of i kind
of wish i'd done this you know
there's what you know the ancients
called emulation zelos right um feeling
feeling that now
you know some of these um are are really
great paraphrases some of them you know
are are uh
decent and uh there's none where i'm
like oh
that's really off
um so i think it's it's a very competent
and
helpful
in general um in reinterpretation of the
end caridian
um i think that it could be helpful for
people who don't know that much about
stoicism i think you could give this to
them
and except for the things that i'm going
to point out in the next section you
know they're going to be getting a
fairly decent sense about what stoic
philosophy is about and how we'd apply
it in the you know modern age
and
they could they could really make use of
this this is a
good book in that that sense
um you know massimo is somebody who's
done his research
um
he's uh giving you a lot of great
background material
and arranging things in helpful ways i
do want to also point out that i really
think that this
conceptual map
is
great you know this is this is also a
feature that i
really like because it lets you look at
each of the
little um
chapters the vignettes right and say
okay here's what epictetus was saying
here's how massimo is reinterpreting it
here's the general theme
this is quite good and many of these are
well the general themes are all tied in
with these updating of stoicism so
that's that's quite a powerful analytic
tool for somebody who wanted to use this
i think that you know
massimo's
reinterpretation of stoicism what he's
representing here is stoicism 2.0 is
you know
pretty much on point there's some places
where i think there could be additional
amplification
but this is a you know this is a short
book it's not intended to do everything
else that his other books available
about stoicism do so i don't think
that's that's something to to criticize
him about
and
you know i do think that um
this
discussion about
how to update stoicism
is is really
quite helpful i think you could take
that
and use it in
stoic meeting groups to say this isn't
the only way that you can do
modern stoicism but here's a very
coherent
way to do
modern stoicism
and and i think you know some people
might disagree with it but i think it
could be actually very useful for that
purpose as a matter of fact i will say
too that i think this could be used
as a book not just to give an individual
person and say well here try out some
stoicism but it could be used for group
meetings as well as a sort of
textbook and
discussion provoker
so
that is you know
that's the good stuff about this book
i do have to admit there are a few
things that i find problematic about
this book and they basically fall into
three categories one has to do with the
price of the book for what you're
getting
another has to do with the fitting
things into
five neat sections when it comes to the
end caribbean material
and then the other is just sort of like
little bits and pieces of things here
where you're like oh that was not
all that well expressed and could be
misleading
for
a reader who doesn't actually
know
what what's being referenced all that
well who doesn't have the background
information so for example here early on
in the book
on page five
we read the only two sets of teachings
we have from epictetus are aryans notes
collected in four books of discourses in
parentheses half of which are
unfortunately lost and a short handbook
or manual known as the encoridian now
reading that that would give you the
impression
that there were four books of the
discourses half of which were lost
that's not right we have four books of
the discourses there were originally
supposed to be eight books
we have four because half of them were
lost and you know that's something that
could be confusing for some people it
does a lot turn on it no it's not like
you know totally getting stoicism wrong
or anything like that but it is you know
a point
i i don't really
like the characterization of temperance
i think it's partly right but it leaves
out some things he he characterizes
temperance in the you know listing the
virtues as the inclination to do things
in right measure neither too little nor
too much yes that's technically correct
but there's also a very very strong
identification and stoicism with
temperance as
self-control as the virtue that's needed
in order to sort of resist the desires
and aversions and and passions so
something got left out that i i don't
think should have been left out now you
know massimo is going to say
that epictetus is actually replacing the
virtues
with the three disciplines which i i
don't really actually buy
as such i think that's misleading as
well so maybe the virtues in a certain
sense don't matter as much
but
i you know i don't think that that
three discipline substituting for the
virtues is right epictetus talks less
about the virtues than other stoics do
but he does talk about them in his
discourses and
even you know
implicitly in the uncaridian
the other thing that i i have
i think is is problematic
and it's inconsistently problematic
is claiming
that here we go the third discipline
that of ascent is meant to improve our
faculty of judgment what epictetus
refers to as pro-erasis that's wrong
crisis would be judgment
and or the rational faculty could be
doing judgment proy racist is the
faculty of choice
which
you know in the
the later uh actual
uh encouraging reinterpretation is
translated here like for example in
chapter 9 as will right
so
that's
that's misleading is it you know are any
of these things that are misleading
going to totally take a reader off track
no i don't think they're really big
things these are maybe
i i don't say that they're just quibbles
because they are
they are indeed problematic but they're
mildly problematic and i think you can
overlook those
i don't buy the
neat fit of
these five sections and all of these
chapters
fitting into those i will say that
there's a long history of doing this
that goes not just in the the modern age
but all the way back to the ancient
period for example simplicius in his
commentary on epictetus and caridian he
does something kind of similar so
actually massimo is in good company in
doing that i just don't i don't think
it's that neat of a fit
i understand why he's doing that
but
you know again i i think
i wouldn't have done it that way but
maybe that's not that big of a criticism
because i didn't write this book
did
the last thing that i'm going to say
about it is that you know looking at the
back
this book is 20
u.s 26 canadian
i think that's even though it's got a
very nice cover design and it's you know
well laid out that's kind of pricey
for a book this size
i think it probably
should be cheaper and i hope that it
sells enough copies to come out in a
paperback form that would be much less
expensive because
that's the one thing that would actually
hold me back from using this i i
wouldn't
ask people to pay twenty dollars
for a book like this if i was you know
teaching
uh using this i i would probably
you know
try to find some work around quite
frankly but those aren't really a lot of
bad things to say so
maybe in some respect
that's a sign of it being a pretty good
book
all right final thoughts um on the whole
i give this a
qualified recommend to get
again i'm not happy about the price but
i think it's quite good i think this is
a book that if you do buy
it it will work as a field guide these
are not brief lessons for living that
you read once and then you like oh throw
the book away
although actually you know what you
could do is you could take this book and
you use it for a couple weeks and then
you pass it on to somebody else that
might be a really
nice way of doing things making use of
this very solidly put together book
it is something that you would use as a
field guide or as a you know vada
maycomb as as uh massimo says in here
carry it around with you and go over it
and over it um
so i i think that it's uh
quite a good book and i do indeed
recommend that those who are interested
in stoic philosophy whether they're at
the very beginner level or intermediate
or even experts i'd say everybody can
get something out of this not least
because massimo is providing some very
competent
reinterpretations
of and caridian's classic lessons for us
you